the basic story of The Roots is is that
you know right out of high school we
started busking on street corners
um like around 91 92. are you you're
playing like buckets right literally
okay so literally the the fastest
version of this like nine hour story is
you know my parents my dad wanted me to
go to either Curtis Institute if you've
seen um
she just got nominated for uh uh best
actress uh uh Kate Blanchett in in tar
oh yeah so the The Institute that that
built that woman that's what my dad
wanted for me
good choice yeah Curtis institute's one
like the the most hardest difficult uh
musical can I jump in one second and
just say this is interesting to me
because your dad famously is part of
this doo-wop yeah my dad was like a
Philadelphia doo-wop Legends in the
hearts and
um and uh I mean killer doo-wop Ben it's
interesting to me that your dad is
pushing you towards this classical thing
when he's from doo-wop okay here's
here's the thing about black people
especially with traumatized black people
we will always like because we're in a
constant fight or flight situation we're
always going to choose safety first
right so in his mind it was like if you
if you join uh uh sort of like an
institution that's like classical music
and we're also big on like respectable
politics like you know we're a suit and
tie that sort of thing
um then you'll get a good job so in his
mind like hey you you one day you two
can make maybe a quarter of a million
dollars and you know that sort of thing
and in my mind I'm like well wait a
minute
I want to be the guy that owns the
stadium that acts playing like why are
you dreaming so small for me and not
yeah for myself so that's a whole nother
I get that though they worry about us
they do yeah and dude I grew up in the
crack 80s where literally every three
seconds someone's dying so it's also a
Russian roulette game that I you know my
future was written so that said he
wanted me to go to
um either Juilliard or Curtis
and so I trained as such you know for
the first six years of my life I went to
one performing art school and then they
took me out during like Middle School to
early high school to go to this like uh
this college prep thing that would have
instantly made me like Harvard material
see we could have been friends there
whatever so
I didn't have friends there
[Laughter]
wherever Charlie Brown goes he's still
Charlie Brown
but anyway yeah anyway so
um I saw this as an app because I didn't
want to go to the the college prep
school right
um even though I've been playing
uh professionally with my father
since I was a kid my first gig was at
Radio City Music Hall like at the age of
12. and I I know this story because he
his drummer like hurt his arm motorcycle
accident yeah and and and your dad said
hey uh kid uh get up there you know the
show yeah and and um and you were like
all right and it's Radio City Musical
right
which is incredible well I knew this so
like the I wasn't nervous at all
um but the sort of antidote to that is
that the second I got off stage I wasn't
and I'm band leading like adults and I'm
12 years old right and I'm bandling but
you know I could play like adults since
I was five
I get off stage and uh I walk backstage
and this black woman says oh my God
young man that was awesome that was
great I was like okay I see you're Susan
from Sesame Street she's like indeed I
am my husband was playing keyboards and
I was like
and
that's real fast
you know those Sesame Street people got
that a lot I would do that now if I saw
someone from Sesame Street I'd throw up
hey Sona think of all the amazing things
in life that are expressions of just you
yeah I mean like the chocolate that you
had on your face when you came in
because you just ate that what was it
you were eating I was eating a giant
cookie giant cookie yeah and that's so
Sona okay or that song you stream over
and over again it's just so you what's
that song For You Twinkle Twinkle Little
Star yeah but it's for my boys I know
still it's nice okay or you know that
podcast that comedy podcast you just
gotta listen to yeah Conan O'Brien needs
a friend exactly is that what you listen
to in your spare time yeah I love it
everything that makes you you makes all
the difference State Farm believes
Insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage selections could be
personalized by you and only you that's
cool I shouldn't shout but this is how
strong away I feel about it you better
choose the plan you want by picking the
options that fit you like choosing to
bundle your home and auto policies is
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about getting the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary I told my parents
uh I want to play with uh musicians my
own age and
you know I want to go to this school
which to them you know to tell your
parents you want to go to a public
school and that sort of thing after
they've done invested in like yeah the
best education to get you and you know
this institution
you know it was a Hail Mary throw but
they they fell for it and
I the plan was that I was going to uh
find that girl for my best friend at our
old school so that she could be his date
for the Junior Prom and you're a good
friend I was a great friend and so I
found out I don't know I still don't
know why a high school student would
occasionally
work in the office like I don't know how
that works but it was her job to hand
out School tokens uh we would get like
free bus tokens to get back because they
we didn't have like a school bus system
I was standing in line for
um School tokens and in front of me
was kind of like a Dreamweaver moment
like we're the prettiest girl in school
like another girl totally unrelated
um was was talking about music which
instantly like my ears were pricked and
she made a wrong Prince reference and
I'm the human version of hashtag well
actually
[Laughter]
you remember when the Smurfs when uh
brainy would say well actually
seconds later they tossed him in the
trash can I was that guy I was like well
actually that was a b side a Japanese
import B-side which is longer than the
album version you're Linus right right
and so
like the four girls just looked at me
like
no one asked you yeah and I I was just
trying my hardest to like impress them
with anything that
probably maybe two months later
I interjected myself again in the
conversation I shouldn't have and I said
well no no it was that song because you
know we we sampled that last night
and they were like sample Warehouse you
know at the studio and it's like who I
said me my group who's in your group and
literally the way that Tariq and I met
like it's somewhere between Like A Tale
of Two Cities and can I just say
something this is a common sitcom plot
yeah of this is a sitcom plot of I got
to impress the girl you're chatting
you're getting over your head you say my
group your group yeah yeah we're in the
studio we want to see you play sure next
week and then you run you run down the
hall guys we gotta form a band that is
literally oh my God that is literally
how I'm in this chair right now so
now the thing was Tariq Tariq really had
an insane gift for talking off the top
of his head so I knew that he had a gift
for doing that and he just happened to
walk by and I was like oh with him so
then I went to the next two periods of
class like in an orchestra and somewhere
in an orchestra class I thought about it
I said nah I gotta warn him so I'm in
the basement
put the uh put like flat of the
Bumblebee in here like
and the lunchroom is on the eighth floor
I'm in the basement so literally
sorry
just sit there work two guys carrying a
plate of glass right a giant wedding
cake and you missed it and then someone
else walked through it
and I was like
yeah
if anyone asks
we're a group and he was literally cool
I don't care
and that is how the roots were born
that's fantastic